Thank you.
You can sit here, Fernando.
Yes.
And then you can sit here.
Nice.
Cool.
Okay, you can press space if you want to play
and then pause if you want to pause,
but you can start talking whenever you want to space.
Sounds good.
So, yeah, getting ready.
Always drink a sip of water or a Gatorade
before getting started
because,
it's like pre-ritual.
This time,
I imagined myself in a tournament
really focusing on what I've ever seen
when people do punze.
They lock their faces to get ready.
The beginning,
very straightforward,
but my side could have been
more distinguished.
My left side seems a little better than my right side.
Attacking forward,
I was very
focused.
One thing I see a lot,
I didn't chamber my hand
and make a fist
when I chambered back to my belt,
but the timing and the motions were prepared
and I extended the motion fully,
tried to snap.
I remember my key-up was
coming from my belly,
so I really exhaled
with a lot of effort.
In this moment,
I wanted to really focus
on the sitting stance,
which comes after this move,
so I might have delayed the move a little bit,
so I was really trying to focus on the stance
because this punze has many different stances
and different preparations,
so for this moment,
I took an extra second
that I should have to go to the back stance.
I tried to extend the side kick as much as possible,
trying to, once again,
once I noticed that I didn't chamber my hand as much,
I tried to extend the side kick as much as possible,
but going forward,
I tried to chamber as much as possible now
that I was in the front motion
because trying to fix those little things.
Trying to extend the side kick,
really trying to frame in the front stance
with the preparation.
Now, I was thinking about
whether my feet were pointing forward,
but once again, I can't check that.
It has to be very natural
and I was wondering the timing
because once you're competing,
the time passes a little bit differently,
so I have to count in my head those eight seconds
in the proper eight-second time
and maybe should I close my fist at the right time
while keeping eyes forward.
I was really worried about which way I was looking
because in korea, you go so many different directions
and just like any other punze,
so your eyes have to be locked in
on which way you're going,
so this time, I was trying to keep my eyes forward
knowing that I was going to go to the back stance,
so I'm going to turn back and prepare right away.
Counting the seconds in my head.
I think I did a good job counting here,
putting my fist right on my palm.
Now, going back.
One, two.
I think I prepared this one.
I didn't prepare as much as the first one,
but I snapped,
and then once I step forward and I key up,
my front stance could have been a little bit longer
because I see that my back leg was a little bent there,
but my chamber hand is there.
My extension was towards the...
My choking motion was towards the neck,
and then I reset around the same area
which I started from.
So, regarding the same size stances,
I was similar,
but I went a little bit bigger stance,
going backward motion,
rather than when I was going forward,
which is why I ended on a further portion of the mat
which I started from.
But yeah, it was longer stance,
going backwards and forwards,
which is why I ended a little bit further back.